I presented a TV series this year,...
...a four - part TV series for Channel 4 called "On Tour with the Queen"...
...where I recreated the Queen's tour of 1953 - 54 of the Commonwealth.
I can't swim and that looks precarious to me.
I mean, I have to say it's probably one of the best jobs in my life.
I think without a shadow of a doubt it was a very brave decision...
...to get somebody like me to kind of shadow the Queen as it were...
...because the Queen is the image of Britain to most people in the world.
It came as quite a bit of a shock really to many of those in the former colonies.
But I wanted to do the gig because the world still has a very 1950s - 60s kind of picture of Britain.
What's your name?
Bill.
Hello, Bill. I'm Kwame.
This is Angela
Hello, Angela.
People really, when I say I'm British, they go, "Pardon? I beg your pardon?"...
...and then will ask me four times, you know...
...and I'll have to kind of give my lineage before they accept it.
Often when people would say, "Why is he asking about the Queen?",...
...there'd be a little bit of anger actually sometimes because I'd be a bit like,...
..."You know what? This is what we look like now."